[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi farò un tè in
compagnia di andrea delogu andrè ma che
bello essere qua guarda io ti sono
riconoscente per essere venuta qui
partiamo subito gli andò c e spine i
sassolini dalle scarpe che tutto quello
che è capito ci portiamo dire anche al
teatro in modo che poi possono andare
avanti da veri amici ok perché tu sei la
classica persona che ammiri e poi
finisci sulla punta ecco perché tu mi
sei autrice di ottimi libri hai fatto un
programma che ha spaccato tonica
ciliegina sulla torta sta prendendo una
casa assurda per cui ti odio cioè se il
cavaliere della repubblica ai tutto il
mondo nel senso cioè era necessario
essere cavaliere tutte queste cose
insieme ma solo di portata da poco sono
stata lasciata e hai sofferto un sacco
perfetto allora sono serie ne possiamo
parlare ti voglio offrire lo a questo
punto un gin tonic a madre questa è vera
questa qui è anni 80 e muscoli
imprevisto non si fa mai nelle
interviste gassato perché adesso tutto
non mi aiuta più taglio
ci tengo che tutti amiamo tutti ok siamo
pronti per una puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
breve storia triste o macchiato di città
la moto del ragazzo trovare tanto ci
viene la moto questo era il padre e lo
so mi sembra così assurdo tipo vuoi
provare la mia moto d'acqua poi comunque
una cosa positiva avete il ciclo vuol
dire che non è incinta del figlio o del
padre perché non puoi saperlo ma è un
bell'uomo magari miglior padre allora
facciamo invece un passo indietro su
questi otto anni io ho un sacco di
amiche e amici che hanno queste
relazioni
immaginarie cogente che in realtà di
base si andasse ad analizzarla non è
interessata secondo te siamo noi che
proiettiamo ho veramente le persone
hanno delle difficoltà a esprimere
questi propri interessi interessi che
rimangono celati se non dici mai a
qualcuno che anche se è interessato ha
interessato beh allora cioè e già questo
è il primo problema il consiglio è meno
pippe mentali facciamo prima a metterci
la faccia a dire quelli che sono i
nostri interessi beccarci il palo perché
la paura di un palo se ne fa prendere
uno dopo otto anni capito
insomma che non potevamo ci
siamo dilettanti qua in figure di merda
nel senso che figura di merda sessuali
cioè se c'era un primo piano tra le
gambe allora tu devi gestire un po di c
o
poi si sono tanto piccole magari non
devi dire che cosa stavano facendo ai
sette anni mi chiedo se no ea martin
carte scoperte dai facciamo c'è una
ragione a me invece capito nel periodo
puberale avevo scoperto i miei ormoni ma
non avevo scoperto il potere del girare
in senso antiorario una chiave non so
perché sdraiato in mezzo al bagno drum
entra mia mamma per in erezione e se
però mi piego subito
che c'è ne fa finta di avvicinarsi o
scuse stammati con la mancia frattempo
ero al culo di fuori immagine di io
avevo i pantaloni abbassati fino a qui
sto mare con la pancia malefatte alto 8
mesi e rombo di tuono e te dice sto mare
con la pancia e tutti 5 senso che non ho
mai pensato uno sta esplorando la
propria sessualità
pensi che sta male al vero
ero sdraiato entra subito fatto questo
cos'è che state vedendo in questo
momento tu figuracce in quell'ambito mai
successo cose mai sindone
mio padre aprì la porta avevo 14 anni o
primo fidanzatino penso che li abbia
perso 23 anni di vita poverino ma crepar
no no si sconvolse basta me ne parola
mamma volevo raccontarvi della figura di
marida più brutta che ho mai fatto in
vita mia la parte dello spi chino il mio
esame del lions ai tempi credevo che il
bartolucci insomma che significa tradire
tirata su thick as litigare e quindi ho
passato dieci minuti buoni a raccontare
quanto spesso io e il mio fidanzato c
gravissimo quanto il tradimento fossero
la pausa cena con la new york decantato
le lodi del tradimento
molto molto a fondo non ti posso dire
secondo me cosa ha pensato e vero che ci
pensa secondo me ha chiesto ma cosa a
tre ma treason così non ci esponiamo in
questo dirò soltanto in mia difesa una
sola volta e stata così piacevole che
non ho più ripetuto casta
con mi ricordo ancora due francesi che
non parlavano mezza parola di italiano
di inglese con il quale a un certo punto
ho usato il traduttore di google colta
beh ma quindi sto sandwich lo famo
sassofono bacio e poi arriva un bacio e
tu improvvisamente
si guarda i primi sua emozionante
storytelling ok e da lì ho detto no vat
ed è quindi era molto più un gioco e
stato un sesso meno ovviamente li chiamo
se l'amore della mia vita ho più un
gioco e se pure creato il mondo giusto
secondo me c'è un qualcosa di romantico
si avvolgente e maggiormente avvolgente
io ho avuto tanta esperienza un pochino
border line con quello che il pensiero
comune potrei far potrebbe pensare
spinta ma io il mio primo bacio gay
diciamo il mio primo bacio dell'amore ok
con quello che poi è stato in un ragazzo
lo da chi in una dark room e mangiano
questo primo bacio sia stato noiosissimo
sul motorino
terribile questa lingua in questa roba
bagnata in htc ma che cosa è macheda che
a 14 anni io sei anni dopo vent'anni il
mio primo bacio proprio la rivolta che
hai fatto l'amore tre giorni dopo
lui non c'è rischio quando siete rimasti
insieme tre anni la mia vera sfida è
stata che non mi sono mai concesso un
momento per stare solo nel liquido e fin
da gol uno è iniziato con un altro fin
da con un'edizione all'altra è il
problema di noi andremo via come il pane
io pensavo io per dire la stessa cosa
una volta divorziata non è stato così
cioè io mi sono divertito un anno e
mezzo fa nessuno mi si prendeva così
cioè in che senso te lo giuro tesoro io
non ho fatto ma su un cafone ho chiesto
se volevo una zolletta
dato lei ma una zolletta scusami io
capisco che tu magari possa mettere un
pochino piano se una donna che però è
economicamente stabile stabile ma in una
società varcare questa cosa non è
ammissibile tu sei il nemico del
patriarcato ho capito ma perché voglio
soltanto
dire
a questo punto vi faccio una partitina
veloce bada al segmento
[Musica]
oltre chiaramente no grazie
che avrebbe potuto dire
grazie
unire pelli non mi può guardare mai più
in faccia e telecity detto prego non ci
ha dichiarato ti sfido a 1 per adulti
sul pezzo tutti quanti ti sta in mezzo
alle chiappe nov
servono per dormire in pochi no no
strano per dormire
proprio
giorni qualcuno che in me un vero io ti
dico sempre che tu sei una quando dico
no quando tutti i file e le foto 6 un
lato quindi è uno che si si mette in ora
ok in inglese beh è un metallo un
metallo molto prezioso
cos'è che c'è anche la rai lasciamoli
dove un tatuaggio è
ancora c'è anche quello e dove usiamo
noi la lametta ecco quindi è
dentro cosa fare
la mattina
va anche detto il romano il bravissimo è
un altro modo per dire patata però
più normale c'è una canzone
è anche un verbo
fermato
quando mangi troppo di tutto la tr
torniamo sul classico ai non è un
cerchio è un raro se lo uccidi porta
sfiga e
ragno di ferro
quando una persona ha col piede
tappezzerà
infiniti minuti a26 achei di achille
lira irrequieto bravi ed è con questo
che ammetto la vittoria contro
effettivamente una persona che ama dato
filo da torcere
torniamo a noi comunque dovremo mettere
sono sposato due figli li amo mia moglie
sempre fedele ma anche di tra con tutto
il resto però quando incontro qualche
mia ex
c'è sempre un incisore niente di
trascendentale come se non si fosse mai
del tutto realmente chiusa piace piacere
e magari è anche quando una volta che
hai una famiglia figli e ami tua moglie
vuoi rimanere comunque fedele ti sei
comunque dato dei limiti a cui non vuoi
mancare di rispetto a concedersi una
scappatella mentale perché no miss
opponendo da
i giorni per me sto seguendo la serie
the fate ignoranti il tema
effettivamente del concetto di monogamia
tradimento che centrale credo che noi se
ci penso veramente
non siamo animali monogami e credo che
noi viviamo questa grande bugia del
l'amore vero con una sola persona perché
oltre a quello non c'è nient'altro che
anche semplicemente un pensiero nei
confronti persone ci fa pensare che ci
sia un problema con un'altra persona no
non c'è raga noi pensiamo che nel
momento in cui una persona non ci prende
completamente vuol dire che non è giusta
per noi no invece a volte sono
giustissime quelle persone ma magari a
in forma in questo caso velatissima
saranno reminiscenze di cose che ci sono
state che ci sta un principo rio bello
gubello sfide io devo lo raccontava
faccio il fuoco io in premessa della
volta la vetrina del cane pratica una
signora in seno prorompente e niente
signora mi senta scusi ma del filetto
vorrei avere una finta po più grande io
perplesso l'aci sismi posso farle una
tetta è una fetta
questo qui è quasi una versione che
vorrebbero fare per quanto mi riguarda
ho scritto un libro anche sulla
dislessia si sono dislessica se sì cosa
vuol dire ciò perché io ora non credo di
essere dislessico mio credo veramente
tante volte di fare dimissioni il
disturbo specifico dell'apprendimento è
molto facile quando è molto presente
diventa una difficoltà perché la scuola
ti insegna in un certo modo quindi tu
aprendo in un altro però ci sono tante
persone che hanno a volte dei disturbi
specifici in modo leggero anche perché
il cervello lavora troppo velocemente ma
cominciano lavorato perché tu non sbagli
mensa cosa in realtà ne ho fatto un po
il mio modo
sciallato di condurre siamo molto figli
di questi binari che sono un provino
imposti del o capisci così ottenevano
vuol dire che non ci arrivi ma poi
italiano e l'esperienza di vita è così
basta che non usare tutti gli strumenti
a viviano per poter insegnare e
tramandare nelle cose veramente uno
spreco anche di opportunità per gli
insegnanti in questo per far capire che
comunque è vero il progetto scoreggiare
perizoma mamma ma sempre sì ma che
impastano ma siamo anche comunque
profondi e abbiamo uno spessore andrea
grazie di cuore facciamo in austria io
ho sempre desiderato baciarti avevo una
cotta per te quando facevo la vocalist e
guardavo questo schermo gigante in
questa discoteca dove mi davo sulle mani
e tu eri lì non mi ricordo che canale
comunque calo importante dove il conduce
di un programma è
carino io accetto un bacio solo se in
bocca certo ma pieni quante sono
e neanche con un po di rossetto che
ringrazio andrea della cooper sia storia
di poste erano tantissimo tempo che non
sentivo e non mi ricordavo perché
preferisco gli uomini
cambiare idea purtroppo comunque le
stanze a parte i ragazzi noi ci
rivediamo qui non so quando ma molto
presto ma molto presto e non so con chi
ma comunque con una persona che non sarà
mai un cavaliere della repubblica
italiana
grazie andrea
[Musica]